Well, this first one doesn't work. It's not really feasible, because your nails
grow independent of how long your hand is. We also can't assert this second one.
We can't simply say that taller people have longer hands. In fact, if we look at
the data, these two people look like they have about the same height. But they
have very different hand lengths, therefore we can't say with certainty that
taller people automatically have longer hands. There's just a trend in that
direction. Also if we look at this trend, we see that people that have about my
hand length, which is 6.75. Tend to have heights around this area. Seven feet is
84 inches, which is way up here. Therefore, it's very unlikely that I'm taller
than 7 feet. But I could be. Remember, this relationship shows a correlation,
not a causation. therefore we can't draw this conclusion, however we can say
with certainty that people who have longer hands tend to be taller